welcome back to pj chain design today we
are going to talk about this
pendant and how to you flow the shape in
between
and arrange the b setting on it are you
ready
let's get started
all right looking at the shape over here
if i exploded this one
you're going to see i have three
components
i got one here got one here and then
this one it's
blending in between so if we can
creating this
basic shape and um and then move it up
and then blend it in between then we'll
get this shape here
now i noticed that it might be a little
bit too hard of the angle here
but we can also adjust it if you want to
that's starting from the scratch so i'm
going to end us
end up setting a one millimeter stone
for my b
setting so i basically just want to draw
a circle
and diameter for one so this is just a
reference for us to look at it
now let's starting drawing the shape i'm
gonna
come in with the arc tool starting with
the zero
and coming maybe something like this
okay and then after that i'm going to
draw another straight line
maybe coming over here
and i would like to use the blend tool
to blend
in between here and here so then i will
get smoother
uh blend over there all i need to do to
get a symmetrical
extra mirror to the other side
all right so we done this one let me
just go ahead to
join it all right so now we got this one
and we want to take a look on our circle
it'll be roughly somewhere like this
right to be more exact i can
simply just moving from the
center of the circle and snapping into
the quadrant there
and i would like to take a look um if
i'm going to use the b
setting and this is a one millimeter
stone and i do like it
this one to be offset and let's say we
want to offset
this curve um both direction so
both side click on it and then the
distance
i would like to have for .6 millimeter
so i give us a little bit room for the
prong and if you want to have a bigger
prong you might want to have a bigger
space
so let's take a look on this and see if
we like the shape
if you feel like the shape is too big or
you don't like it
you can change it from there okay
so the second thing is we need to giving
[Music]
a curvature there so to make a curve we
can
simply pull up those four points and
just moving up like this
and notice that
it is a kink there and doesn't look too
nice so what we wanted to do is
actually to rebuild this guy first
and we want to rebuild to the even
number and the important part is here is
the degree is three
and we click ok now let's go ahead to
move
maybe those six point and we want to
move it out a little bit
and maybe this one and this one you want
to coming out a little bit more
to get something like this all right so
let's give it a try
we are going to come into the top view
and the top view with this point
i'm going to creating a cross section so
let's go to
use the rounded rectangle
snapping the center to here
and we're going to set one millimeter
stone so i want to have the length about
1.2
by 1.2 and just give it a little bit
round corner
something like this okay
and then uh let me did it this circle we
no longer need it
and let me just uh mirror to the other
side
snapping to the zero holding the shift
and you'll get something like this all
right and i also might
wanted to adjust this point to make it a
flow better to make it blend better
later on
and tilted the angle something like this
maybe have it go all the way to the
other side
all right let's give it a try we wanted
to do the
sweep one rail and you want to pick up
the rail
cross section cross section make sure
all the arrows are facing interior
and then hit enter and you want to
record the history as well
all right so now we get that first shape
we are going to have this going up
roughly about the shape making a copy
and if the shape is kind of too close
it's blocking it and it will be hard
enough for us to set the stone
we actually want to move this toward
inside so let me move it 0.3 millimeter
on both side 0.3 so that way it's not
blocking there the stone will flow
better
all right so now we need to blend those
two let's see if
the blend surface will work we're going
to
pick up the blend surface and chain age
is equal
yes we're gonna go from here
to here and make sure they are all
aligned
and we'll have something like this and
because this is
too big of the turn so your blend look
really weird over there so let me see if
i can
adjust this let's go bigger
this goes smaller and this is still not
working really well
so a board and we are trying other way
now what i like to do is we have the
original sweep one rail the rail over
there
so let's do this instead of blend
surface i would like to
blend the curve and we want to blend
from this
end to this end you can see it's like
really tight there
so actually i'm going to edit this curve
a little bit more
let's click ok um so we got this curve
here
and we do want to move it
on our side view to make it look nicer
so we want to go
moving this point coming down
maybe something like this and also maybe
you want to rebuild it to get more point
to edit
so let's say we gonna go with the 7
and then maybe moving
those out
something like that so you have enough
room for your chin to go
through and maybe this one
up a little bit okay so let's give it a
try
so we want to use the sweep one rail and
we want to pick up this rail
and this is a cross section and this is
another cross section
and make sure they are aligned well
facing the same direction
and then we'll get something like this
make sure that you don't have the kink
there if you do you need to adjust this
one so let's go ahead to record history
and we can turn on the control point on
this
curve here and see if this is too tight
if it is just too tight you may want to
moving this one
out a little bit more so that way you
will get more room for
the chin that you're going to use
okay so double make sure everything look
uh
nice in the render view you don't have
too much of the kink there if you do
maybe like right here
you want to keep adjusting until it is
smooth
so all we need to do now is having this
guy here
and since it's symmetrical
then we can mirror to the other side
so now it is for the song setting part
we do need to have a curve for us to
erade the stone so let's use extract the
iso curve and we want to extract it from
this surface and snapping into the
midpoint so make sure the midpoint is on
and i'm going to mark it into the red
color so let me bring in the stone i'm
going to mark the stone
into the cyan color and you can download
this stone at the description below
and we simply want to bring the stone to
that
first close to that first point and we
also wanted to tilt it the stone
follow this curve have the girdle
sticking into the surface
nicely as much as you can and i try to
adjust the
stone into the middle as much as you can
so we're going to use the command array
along curve
and we are going to pick up the object
is
actually our stone and the base curve
is this curve so so far i have
two here so i'm kind of guessing maybe i
need 20
and you also wanted to make sure you
have a little gap in between
it's about 0.1 to 0.2 millimeter
apparently this is
too big so maybe i need a little bit
more let's try
30 and 30 is kind of blocking each other
so let's go back to
26 and 26 is still too close so
maybe we just need a little bit more so
let's try
23. so then i will have one just right
in the middle
okay so it looks alright and then we'll
click
enter and then next things i wanted to
do is
do the prong so basically
i wanted to draw a straight line
something like this and i wanted to pipe
it
for the size like that and for this
prong
apparently it's a little bit too big i'm
going to scale it down
and move it right there
and that's moving in to
about here make sure that you want this
prong is
cutting equally on both sides of the
stone
like this in my case i have a shared
prong
in your case you might want to have
a full prong for each of a stone it's up
to you depends on your design
this might be need to be a little bit
smaller i usually don't like the prong
is too big
but i need it too big enough without you
know breaking it
at the settings so let me move it to the
other side
and making a copy
we need to have the prong before setting
a little bit taller
so they need to over the table let me
move it up a little bit
and if you want to know more about the
stone setting i do have a class
online class for it that explain all the
detail
about the song setting principle for the
3d modeling
okay so we're going to flow one more
time that's using the same command
array along curve and i'm going to pick
up this one and this one
and we're going to pick up the base
point
and basically it will be the same number
as we use
there so we get something like that now
i'm missing two
on the top simply just having those two
prong
and mirror to the other side and double
make sure that some of the problem is
stick it on the bottom you might need to
move it back again
or when you try to arrange over there
you might want to bring in again so you
don't have to do them individually
and with the chin on and you can also
cut the
pilot hole in the back to get the better
light for the stone and that will be our
infinity
pendant i hope you enjoyed the video if
you are new to the rhino
check out my course on my website that
is an
excellent one for a beginner thank you
for watching
and i'll see you next
[Music]
foreign